[Music]
when you have married the man you sit
over there okay
the Vietnamese would normally eat our
lives whenever life that's been more
expensive Musa that is the mountain rot
you're killing me on it I said that
people who can hit this one look at it
yeah be careful you want some more tea
what kind of snake is Cobra a Cobra
we carefully because they can spit out
the verdict unbelievable
yeah huge i more than losers taste like
it tastes like questioning like a
chicken people usually like barbecue it
mm-hmm everything is alive when it's
dead it's not good anymore I'm all for
trying fresh ingredients but having seen
tonight's specials I'm wondering if I've
bitten off more than I can chew okay so
what do you fancy rant on toast how
about we try there snake celebrates
seven ways Franz Steve Christ even stood
and barbecue here we go the snake in
Vietnam people they say to make you very
healthy and short and good for your sex
mr. fat when was last time you had to
say when the name like that I'm supposed
to get anything in Vietnamese and yet
sangwoo's out to win one nine five times
yeah so you last longer once you've
eaten a snake okay yeah who's gonna kill
the snake you see how to cure this
[Music]
Jesus t six-foot Jesus the thought of
eating that turns my stomach they would
check the heart but I can't back out now
you okay yeah I'm fine
I couldn't feel better so here we go
what's that that's the snake heart it's
been it's still beating
Wow [ __ ] delicious you can feel it
going down in here
oh come on let's go are you scared
don't scared the power it's a one night
fighter one not five times unfortunately
my wife is he 7,000 miles away wow
that's a how strong the man is yeah yes
hold up boys that this is the buyer of
this name
look at the color no no no no no okay so
I done the heart you can do the pile
yeah you ain't right
excuse me I'm just taking them already
come on guys
I've just taken the heart for God's sake
what's the matter with you lot Cheers
wait yesterday man you're not bouncing
the head like you yes okay here we go
after the bizarre drinking game comes
the main course and there's a different
dish for each bit of the stage look at
the skin you see the skins that
Vietnamese way they like it anything
it's very chewy Jesus after the skin
comes the innards this one it's a nice
thick snake what snake doc snake guts
this is good this is good
oh here we go what's that that's another
dish come on
are we seriously gonna be this why not
like something out of a science museum
the bone has been they have a lot of
calcium okay it's good yeah I'm feeling
over the [ __ ] moon